all right guys match fixing in esports
is one of the worst things a player can
be accused of
even if they're proven innocent it's the
type of thing that can hang over them
their entire career
today i want to tell you a story about a
rainbow six siege player who is
banned for attempted match fixing they
say that it was all a joke and that they
did nothing wrong
but we were told that they were serious
and that they've allegedly done this
before
[Music]
so before we get into the story you guys
might have noticed that the score
esports has been streaming over on
twitch.tv slash the score
esports we got our talk show clouded
that airs every wednesday at 1pm eastern
where me dan keith and colin break down
the biggest stories from esports and
streaming
so make sure you follow the channel and
you hit that notification button so you
know exactly
when we go live okay let's get back to
it so this story came to my attention
when an anonymous source contacted me
and said pro player share me had
contacted a player about match fixing an
upcoming gsa match
the gsa is an amateur league with the 40
000 euro prize pool
that feeds into the eu challenger league
pro players like pangu and kanto
ricketti are required to play in the gsa
because
basically ubisoft sees this as a way to
give amateur teams
development time and experience against
the best that eu proceeds has to offer
commentary jewish kepke and ocarina
what's he show me [ __ ]
and the winner of gsa earns a spot in
the eu challenger league but here's the
weird part
pro league teams competing in gsa so
your g2s or your rogues of the world
can't claim that eu challenger spot
because well
they're already in pro league so
essentially if rogue were to win gsa
the next highest ranked amateur team
would claim that spot
now cheremy and his amateur team devise
and compete in gsa and they're actually
pretty good they managed to beat both
rogue and
team secret two teams who compete in eu
pro league
my source who requested to remain
anonymous provided a translated version
of the conversation
in which jeremy asks another player if
they'd be willing to throw an upcoming
gsa match against
rogue the other person in the
conversation basically asks if jeremy's
suggesting that they match fix
and share me replies yes from there
cheremy doubles down and says that this
match against rogue isn't important to
the other team
and that rogue winning would help devise
and get closer to clinching that
challenger league
spot remember as an amateur team you
don't even have to win
gsa you just have to be the highest
ranked amateur team
in the league so you can imagine winning
the gsa league would be a huge step
up for an amateur team like devising
from there we were told that the player
talking to jeremy got in touch with his
general manager
and they went back and forth as to
whether or not they should report this
incident to ubisoft
soon after that our source told us that
the player talking to cherymy
was contacted by another siege player in
the gsa
and they said that cheremy had allegedly
done this before
in something called the saturday league
and the saturday league is basically
another amateur league that players can
compete
in it was after hearing that ceremony
had allegedly done this before
that the person talking to share me
decided to file a report to ubisoft
now i talked to shermy and he says that
he eventually heard that ubisoft was
looking to ban him because of this
conversation so he went to the person
that he had the conversation with
and said hey man i was just joking can
you tell ubisoft that
according to shareme there was no match
fixing here it was all just a joke but
eventually ubisoft handed cheremy a
six-month ban
that ends in january of 2021 ubisoft
germany eventually made a statement
about this
and translated it reads quote as a
result of an investigation because of
attempted match fixing while playing in
the 2020 version of the gsa league
we decided to ban cheremy from team
devison for the next six months
from all esport competitions end quote
now after the ban was announced
jeremy doubled down on social media
saying that he wasn't serious about
match fixing and that it was all a joke
and he also thinks that he probably
won't be able to come back from this
and like i said i talked to him about
this situation and here's what he had to
say about the ban
and i messaged him like yay why don't
you throw the same way that you did
today against like
uh rogue on the on the last match day
and then he said like yeah
uh is this match fixing what you want
for me and i was like yes
ha ha ha ha like like like choking
around
like at this moment like i never
expected like
him or like anyone to like take
screenshots of this conversation and
then just
send it to ubisoft like a day or two
days later
uh ubisoft contacted devising the orc i
played for
and told them that i am like locked and
i'm not allowed to play it till like
they know what happened there now the
response to cheremy's ban
online is largely in his favor some
people are calling
six months too harsh and other people
are wondering why he got
banned at all since he didn't actually
match fix
now you have to imagine that cheremy
attempting to match fix
is what led ubisoft to give him a
six-month ban if he
actually matched fixed the punishment
would be much worse and shermy says that
he was pulled into a conference call
with ubisoft executives
and they said that hey you can tell us
your story but it's not going to affect
the ban
you're still getting a six-month ban no
matter what happens
we have like a phone call with like uh
the german ubisoft center and there were
like three people in it i don't know who
they're all in but it was like the head
chef from the german office
yeah like two other guys and they the
first thing they told me like
yeah decision is already done you can
tell us your
story now but it wouldn't affect the
outcome and when it comes to the
allegation that shami attempted to match
fix in that amateur
saturday league he says that never
happened
no i never did anything like that and i
don't know what he even said
like even him said it you tried this
before and i asked him what do you mean
but i
like hands down it's where i'm alive i
never like
did like any match fixing in any league
with this chat that i was with him
it's not even match fixing i didn't even
gave him anything like normal match
fixing would be like oh yeah i give you
money and you
you throw your game or something like
that it was just purely chat
i don't even know how like they are
managing to say like oh yeah
your career is now over and you get
banned for six months like i don't
understand
now i don't know if jeremy was serious
or if he was just joking but what i do
know
is that you probably shouldn't slide
into the dms of somebody you don't know
that well
and say hey wanna do some match fixing i
mean why even give ubisoft the chance to
slam down that band hammer
critics of cheremy point to pengu who
makes jokes about match fixing on social
media implying that if pengu can do it
why can't share me well to be honest
there's a big difference between a tweet
that everyone can publicly see
and a dm conversation one you never
match fix
in public and two it's much harder to
tell if someone's joking when they slide
into your dms
look i have no idea if shermy was
serious or not and i have no idea if
this ban is too harsh
but i do know that if you want to be a
pro player joking about match fixing
online it's probably not a good idea
colton has just been talking about the
fact that his legs have been giving him
issues over the last couple of months
and he doesn't know why
and my old ass there are days when i get
out of bed
and i [ __ ] tweak something in my back
and that's it for me
i'm 25 years old and i have these
[ __ ] problems i don't know what's
happening
should probably see somebody about it i
have no excuse
i have no excuse i'm doing ymca now
i have no [ __ ] excuse